[Music]
[Music]
and that is the classic sound of three
people who are just pretending to know
what they're doing
also known as the morning grinders
direct your thoughts and prayers to our
thoughts and prayers and will direct our
thoughts and prayers to yours
I'm Courtney scoffs if you don't like my
jokes I don't care
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
Courtney scoffs hosting somewhere in
Texas is not gay Jared he is deathly
afraid of clowns follow him on Twitter
but not Instagram at not gay Jared
hosting with him is Jean Morgan Jr he
claims to like biking but refuses to
shave his hairy man legs right follow
him on Twitter at junior it is morning
grinders weekend the real simple weekend
I know what other people are trying to
claim that phrase out there I don't know
but it's it's at our creation as it is
and this is of course if you're watching
this on YouTube we are happy to give you
a free episode as the capstone of
hashtag three crowd a week so this
morning grinders you can get the show
once a week
it's really awful I suggest not watching
it it will ruin your life and socio
tv-ma Club that'll calm slash my club
join and you get this once a week and
but this is a free episode you get
exciting great not-so-great and this is
where it's like it's not really your
reward no no the problem is you'll end
up strangely liking the show and you
won't know why don't have to watch next
week just because we're all to prove add
sitcom that runs for seven years one
reason this is like why do I watch this
show like the same reason you watch a
car accident on the side of the road
look away exactly so this is part of the
show where things start to go downhill
so first story what two scoops of ice
cream
not until gay men can get married says
Ben and Jerry Courtney we're ever on the
site fill us in darling so much fun
writing this on the site so you know
when you go to get two scoops of ice
cream kind of like with Starbucks and
you go to get coffee you just kind of
want the coffee well now in Australia if
you want two scoops of the same flavor
ice cream you can't because two men can
not get it on in the marriage bed with
the government's approval or is it
because I think it would include women
too right and women yeah yeah so they
can't get their sister love on after
they smashed how many people have
clicked away so so you get a straight
now you have to get mixed flavors of ice
cream you cannot get idea that sounds
like a better deal to me that's right
okay now when I was writing this I was
also thinking of different Ben and
Jerry's flavors inspired by this yeah
like tallywacker toffee or titties and
cream oh that's yoga lore everything Ben
and Jerry stands for yeah but they still
make the best ice cream you can also
there's an ice cream elsewhere there's a
lot better ice cream out there there are
just a good mass-produced ice cream how
about that yeah Mitchell's in Cleveland
Ohio I would just go there and buy it
like two scoops with a buddy and then
switch them right in front of them and
they'd flick them off and be like hahaha
we worked around your silly sister ice
cream is fornicating that's right we're
cross pollinating or something there's
always work arounds next story Alamo
Drafthouse I think this is it oh yes
no no it's in New York no no it's Austin
is this another one it's in New York's
in New York City don't screw us up this
is a New York draft outs the name of a
theater in New York yes there's Alamo
Drafthouse is all over the place this is
in New York maybe Austin is going with
them I'm going with them
so made us more dropped out somewhere
now this is a woman only screening of
Wonder Woman and of course men are upset
because oh well listen I I gotta tell
you so I don't really care a whole hell
of a lot about this but the thing that
made me laugh hysterically was the
follow-up tweet that they sent out and
saying hey sorry we're also going to let
people in who identify as women and I
was like jackpot baby I'm walking in
that door I'm identifying as a woman for
two and a star 'get rich environment I'm
the only dude this is the price I would
pay to get air in the intern as Wonder
Woman and that theater at all of his
glory you need to take that opportunity
you need to take that on the road people
somebody else tweeted out they're like
oh you should be okay with a white only
screening of a theater and somebody else
is like no it's not even close to the
same thing yeah no it actually is the
same thing I don't think no I think it's
here's the thing I was thinking about
last night it's like I don't really care
you're always gonna be a screening
amends only screening of Goodfellas you
guys have fun you know no that's not
what happened
[Music]
that's the point I mean that's that's
the thing it's like in the a lot of men
are trying to point that out and the
women just weren't hearing it yeah
private event I don't really care like
if you don't have a woman only screening
have a woman when screening but then
don't get upset if men decide to have
men's only screening well what if what
if people have what if they want to have
a blacks only screening of Straight
Outta Compton right or some other like
Country Club douchey movie and whites
only screening for it like it's doing it
I mean
they can but people would lose it people
would absolutely lose their minds and so
on this it's acceptable it's like oh
because it's women here's the real
problem that's what's annoying it's like
you guys these ladies they are the one
who crude a lot of these liberals are
the ones who created this environment
where you can't have this stuff you
can't have nice things anymore this
wouldn't have been a big deal prior
here's the trying to you man
interrupting me I mean I'm done we're
two men in arrears the problem that no
one is talking about everyone is
overlooking that is going to be the
showing from a hell because you know
everyone's browsers gonna be texting on
their phones tweeting taking selfies and
ignoring the movie that movie is gonna
get zero just as methane that's showing
there's gonna be a quiz after the movie
to see if you actually watched watch it
pass/fail rates could let me have no
attention span for movies I've seen this
awkward you are gonna get so with
nothing in my whole day I do not agree
with this fellow tweet him did you
imagine though could you imagine a men's
only showing one woman yeah there'd be a
little few cat calls probably it would
just be she's hard I mean she showed us
tissues and lotion go on in my life that
is the worst lead-in for anything I've
ever heard
yes okay so Mark Zuckerberg gave a
speech I think is that Harvard that's
where he came from s yes
yeah dropped out of to become the
welcome you just went back to graduate
from yeah yeah whatever for him
commencement speech stream the YouTube
with hilarious captions so not only does
his stream go up with his own platform
with caption errors which is hilarious
see also because it justifies sometimes
our streams I'm like hey if Mark frickin
Zuckerberg can get his own day this is
one with this do me some slides okay for
you to screw up cuz Mark Zuckerberg
screws exactly that's we're going with
this that's the line but
less talked about in the in the
mainstream media is what the hell's the
monopoly guy doing there why is no one
that the crew the Titanic behind him
like why is this not front-page news
iceberg you know they're British so
right ahead dead ahead
I just want to say probably wasn't
texting while I was watching that movie
but paying attention well that's
probably inaccurate you really kind of
held on to that one too you brought that
back a few minutes later I can't wait to
throw this in by the way why didn't they
just like load that all the passengers
that were about to sink into the ocean
like onto the iceberg there that never
crosses mine this seems like they didn't
come to a full stop did you not watch
the movie and dotted a bunch of holes in
it about things happen under years ago
get over it are me lowers physical
standards for lady infantryman oh boy oh
that's offensive infantrymen I visit
them on your part accordingly
who still can't happy this is we wrote
about this you are about this about it
so yeah I'll back you in this cake is it
there are pretty low they're already
pretty low and a lot of these standards
most basic like CrossFit women can do so
if the thing is the the feminists have
been screaming differ military equality
or whatever like four years they finally
are allowed in and it turns out
you really want to it's like ladies lady
this is why we tell men how brave and
strong they are so that they can go
fight these wars for us that's right
it's right this is one of the dumbest
evolutionary things you've ever done
ladies ladies ladies
stop it they're doing all the work what
is you deal yeah in a way that is the
ultimate power because you have treated
is the ultimate lies I was like finally
getting a guy to take out the trash
something going no I can take out the
trash no I'm strong enough to do it when
you take out the trash I just want you
to know that I can do it I can't I can't
do that I'm not strong and opulence
before I do it sweetie
why women thank you that are less
evolved back teacher that's that's why
guy the guys have been doing this with
laundry for millennia we screw it up
we'll put Reds in with whites on purpose
on purpose and then we're never asked to
do laundry again that's genius brilliant
it is you guys the opposite direction
and Casey Casey and I were texting about
this I'm going oh my gosh and she's like
look I would rather let them fight the
wars and I'll just stay in the kitchen
I'm like right and casseroles by the
delicious appreciate it yeah we do love
casseroles women who made airplanes and
bombs during war that was fine they had
a job that was cool too except they
weren't on the Rosie the Riveter that's
right dumb lady's story yeah couple this
is great travels 14 miles with passed
out man on their trunk how's the illness
they had been going hey I wanted that
too was this like an on purpose like
slow roll kind of passed up he passed it
on the trunk and they've got a spoiler
on the back of their car yeah I was just
pushing this boy back so he breaks down
gosh did you just say that out loud
I just said how the hell would you say
you're interrupting me so I don't know
splaining I don't know you have to
rewind it court yeah I don't remember
what do they have like a two cylinder
car like that doesn't even exist but
what if they I mean like anytime 65
miles and I understand getting up to
that speed with somebody on the back of
your car theoretically but when you hit
the gas the people in the car typically
roll back a little bit into the seat
you're telling me this guy didn't roll
off was he holding on
that's the spoiler this freakin wall
it's like a one and a half inch bump
okay like it's yeah I'm not arguing that
it's right or wrong I'm just saying
that's what happened I'm just trying to
man play the spoiler the bottom line is
next time a hobo asked you to pay for a
damn bus ride pay for it he will get
very difficult won't you say hey I've
got a spoiler you want to pass out and
write on sounds good I'm down heroin
injection sites playing faces new
challenge from voters a new challenge a
new challenge because yeah it was going
swimmingly before this is this is your
side of the country
yeah you feel Sam what the hell's going
on here so Seattle is just it's gay Bay
North so believe it San Francisco just a
little bit smaller and a little bit
cleaner because it's so cold and we
can't have all those homeless people
running around sure
so what a so it goes to the we want to
have clean needles so that people are
more safe when they're injecting here
went into their eyeballs so now they're
gonna have injection sites so if you
want to go shoot up heroin now there's a
safe now you have a hair with a safe
space
yeah heroin mm-hmm why did you have your
priorities straight out there there's
nothing else you can possibly be working
on Oh Seattle's nuts it's crazy
come to the land of the free courting
just come home of the brave because
Seattle here's will move here's what's
annoying about the liberals as they do
pick the prettier places that's true
yeah they ruin it with condoms and use
heroin needles
yeah so you know people mean on stuff
it's not worth it yeah
no mm-hmm it's better than living in a
place where there's so much urban sprawl
you just roll your eyes at every traffic
like and I'm going to go with that over
the used heroin needles that stuff taken
at the bus stop that story I think I'm
gonna be okay the conceptual penis this
is a social construct awesome yeah level
11 yeah this they Rock these people did
you read the story I did I didn't read
it again I read it well then why don't
you leave gerald since you know you have
penis privilege these guys got together
and wrote an article like a totally fake
article just throwing out all of the
like jargon of social justice warriors
and crazy professors around the United
States and actually went back through
with a fine-tooth comb and said this
can't mean anything like let's make sure
it doesn't actually say anything about
like we don't want it to actually and it
get published and their basic premise
was that the penis the male penis wasn't
a real thing that it was like a social
construct that was also a responsible
for many many things but for climate
change and they said that when you man
spread how men sit with their legs
spread wide that year you're effectively
raping the environment around you these
are the kind of points that these guys
made and the article was accepted and
published I need to do that we need to
just start releasing it give a platform
we have an audience if we start just
releasing me I think I would have so
much fun the problem is I'd be laughing
the entire time it's true the problem is
it would be published again and again
just again and I mean you know I've told
Stephen like well this is it like this
is my career there's no way I could do
anything else there
just gonna Google me a [ __ ] that's gonna
collapse was attack the Beehive
I wanted a beehive and all men who voted
Bernie Sanders I mean it's true ticked
off at least half the country it's over
so I mean what who cares now I'll write
about the conceptual penis or the
conceptual [ __ ] you know Gina I want to
hear about that for next week's show I
think you should about it I mean to
write about it yeah I think you should
write about the blogger who did
something interesting and made bread
next story so this tweet happened
this tweet went out and I don't know did
you have you guys seen these clips
coming out of Donald Trump coming off
the tarmac with Melania and trying to
take her hand and she swats it away
awkward the people just have hone and
not like there's like it happened like
that was twice now yeah and it is the
funniest thing because you know there's
like that really like Melania she don't
put up with nothing you know there was
some bitter argument and you know I
don't how the Trump is today is even
addressed it but you know did it would
be like something really just stupid
excuse me he wouldn't just come on say
yeah we had a tiff it's gonna be like
some epic explanation for why she would
possibly swipe his head other than she
didn't want to hold it like in Saudi
Arabia did you see the crown prince's a
hot harem I want to go hang out there
for a little while I'll be back you know
what hold my hand now what probably
better than all women Wonder Woman
screening probably aren't the kind of
girls you want to be around and in a
case this guy trolled it hard with this
gift open trying new there it is they
did it really well too it's seamless
that is so good just what I laugh so
hard I lose I'm sorry I know
rotary picked but I laugh so hard all
the photos of the Pope just looking so
pissed
but you know they're fake news right I
know some of it is but the it is still
so funny they've got pictures of him
smiling and trumpet you know what's you
know it's not fake news though Trump
gave him like some old collection of
books or something like that is like the
the the big you know presentation of the
gifts do you know what this I'm sorry
Cory I know you're Catholic but I know
you know he's a douche bag - this douche
bag Pope gave Trump give him a copy of
his old letter to Obama on climate
change so he went into a lease brush it
up a little bit no days off it's like
morning up on standard everyday
georgia-pacific paper plain old reused
recycled manila envelope and pass it off
that's the Trump the official gift I
don't even want to know what this Pope
is like at birthday parties basically
that's the Pope trolling Trump right
there so lame like I'll just give him a
real gift and then like afterwards be
like oh by the way with here are my
thoughts on climate change which by the
way oh you know what would have been
funny
this is crass and I'm don't apologize
just do it all I'm not like the vaginal
area of a statue and just say you can
grab this whenever you want they were
going through like a carrot annika stage
and so they removed all the genitalia
they did from statues and stuff so like
if you've got if you've got a vagina
lying around just give it to him and say
so you don't have to grab anymore gets
extra vajayjays okay I'm sure that's
gonna satisfy battle but with all the
cool stuff in Vatican City that's the
best thing you can go like you've got
like that volume with all kinds of cool
stuff down there and you give them paper
on the climate change it is I will
concede it is pretty funny
it is if I look
like just troll this pure troll level
that is do you think the like Pope and
you know some of the Cardinals are like
sitter like what do we give Trump what
do we give the man who has everything
well we have some pretty cool stuff in
the Vatican wait we give him an old
letter that we sent to Obama but he
absolutely mic drop
mic drop all right that's good grinder
this is where we tweet out voice really
I don't know really what this is is Gary
the the news has been so awful lately
that we tweet for your help and because
we got a paralyzed show map the true and
so we take your precious questions and
turn them into answers because you want
the answers they want you want the
answers be careful what you ask for you
just might get it
so ask a grinder time when he matters if
you were a gun and gun what gun would
you be I think as Carter would be an
ac-130 gunship ah that's my name is
dream accordion what gun would you be do
I have to be a gun I think you should be
a flamethrower because you hate
everything
I'll just so you know I would be
whatever is on the the front of the a-10
what is it the Warthog things just like
incredible yeah thirties like millimeter
P 30 millimeter for 30 million Canada I
would be that cuz that dominates it is
pretty awesome and I don't think that
you dominate I don't know if I dominate
but maybe I do I don't know I don't know
we'll find out later Courtney won't we
maybe well this is where the [ __ ] you
can expect the show to go just downhill
really fast into just any times we're
working for it we're digging speed up on
the hill questions one player to play
crumple or fold over under traditional
or squatty potty okay that's too many
questions there's a lot of questions
Courtney how do you like take [ __ ]
[Laughter]
to ply to play boy yeah you never want
to surprise yourself and traditional but
I do want a squatty potty you do mm-hmm
the cheap at Costco you can get them
there there you go yeah boom boom
Gerald we don't want to care if we don't
really care about yours I dominate the
toilet every time I sit down and I told
that the toilet knows I dominate you
don't you know vacations there Cory
Darth Vader or Emperor Palpatine comes
from Troy James I think I know the
answer to this one what do you think
Courtney I think it's Boehner oh gosh I
would pick Palpatine because Palpatine
is like so diabolical Vader's just like
whatever you are the Dark Lord of the
way yeah yeah yeah
you're just pure evil either way yeah
you're evil money grinders what what's s
quarter like to work with or be honest
is he a tyrant Oh Charlotte Charlotte
little darling above her lip what is
that in the pic I don't know Charlotte
you're gonna get us into a lot of
trouble here worms that she is uh-huh go
for it who wants to answer this question
with Stephen the longest which would be
actually arid no no longer though that
would be me I know okay
that was I've been around since the
early days of Carter he's fantastic to
work for he's the best boss dominated
you meant that you stuck your nose in it
and bring it around he's an interesting
fellow
that's very good good guy but if we were
roasting Stephen what would we roast him
about how about how about Sam I can't
just not like something and yes yes deem
its he never ever ever ever ever says
that this isn't good to me this is like
this is terrible this is why and here's
something else that's fantastic and
that's why it's fantastic and everybody
should get that and screw this yeah like
the donut thing what is that about what
it's not a donut thing Steven it's a
donut dummy it's like a pizza thing well
thing is like and he also mispronounces
things he died like remember do you
remember the other day when he said
something about somebody's pronunciation
of a word he's like oh I didn't know
that was the thing I'm like all right
Mike it's like the black color they got
a black there it's like my favorite part
of last night was when I was was when
Tommy correct him on geography that was
pretty awesome what yeah what yeah he
said something about Fargo she's from
South Dakota yeah he loves her she's
like we all about lost it because it was
just classic that's gonna live on
forever did Cory yeah Courtney let's go
party this is time to air your
grievances let's go chef a little
episode I mean she won the honest answer
the honest answer is Stephen is very
familial so he kind of wants everyone to
be a friends and family and then
sometimes we have those kind of scuffles
that's very I would say like siblings
where you kind of you love each other
but also sometimes I I told him one time
you're like the brother I never had and
sometimes that means I want to give you
a bear hug and sometimes that means I
want a bear to hug you yeah that's true
force and I think and that's I think
that's kind of how it is like we're very
all kind of close and tighten it and I
think we would all defend each other to
the death but then sometimes it's like a
family where we just kind of want to
kill each other
yeah and Courtney's like that crazy
sibling in the family that just randomly
wants to kill everybody for no reason I
feel like she's one bad weekend away
from not being able to keep it on lock
anymore and just going off this is why I
need a vacation like this is why you
need to have a glass of wine
occasionally I understand
yeah yeah free now you can give me a
couple of pumps
Jack me the happy pills on the happy
juice so this tweak came into US and I
thought this was just the best thing
ever I don't even know who did this I
can't even read down the screen but I
don't much time on their hands I love
that so much who is all okay so so
clearly we got a bench up here that in
the top hat yeah and I think it looks
behind them to the left you've got
Stephen and to the left of that I think
that's probably Dave Rubin is that right
yeah it's Rubin yeah Andrew Clavin and
then me being super freakin creepy in
the background that's right that's
reasonable it's reasonable I mean you're
the guy who slowly starved to death a
tiny animal that's right and hey I
appreciate all the people on Twitter who
spoke up about it I've been for in the
making how do you know you've been
forgiven for that family
the first difference forgiving yourself
forgiving you which has not occurred and
not forgiving you somewhere I think Hugo
has forgiven me also that was the name
goodies from Down Under
he's an Australian creature this keeps
getting worse you need to stop this gets
worse morning bloopers this is uh well
it's a temporary name it's not
incredibly ingenious but we have one
today it's reflection of the show the
show perfect
so anyone who saw a lost that show um
you know you're the intern we miss you
yeah but uh
behold can you move in all right so I'm
gonna yank off your headphones grab you
by the hair let's go with me stay yeah
cuz it's gonna be one I'm gonna yank off
your headphones
just do the shots get the blood capsule
in his mouth Edward here's the motion I
want from you punch you know we have fun
here and sometimes we want to kill each
other and sometimes you just sometimes
you do both at the same time it's
therapeutic it is my favorite part last
night was when you when you alluded to
the color of the shade of Stephens lips
beforehand did you see that Gerald I did
not sure I was like this program is a
watch no I don't pay him enough he had
something to do with a red puppet on
Sesame Street
yes sir sexual act it was distracting me
his lips were clearly red everyone was
talking about he said tell me what you
said cuz I think I know what you said oh
my god his lips red red and he didn't
believe me it's like I think there's
just the lights cuz everything is the
light to someone else's fault and I said
no do you like your lips are really red
like you guess where have you been
blowing Elmo or something because I know
you so well I'm proud of the comment I'm
like that was frickin gold I mean you
should have get a raise for that one the
things we talk about here
just like that so anyways this has been
morning grinders it's always a waste of
your time but we invite you to take part
in it every week
Friday mornings laterthe CARICOM slash
my club we hope you enjoyed the free
episode because he didn't really we
should have paid you to watch this
that's that's the bottom line spree deal
with it this free deal with it you saw
the ride you bought the ticket so
Courtney
yeah Dark Lord doc Lord send us out
I think that that was really good I
think if you if you've liked this
episode you might want to talk to
somebody about it
like a professional a mental health
professional and if you didn't like it
don't tweet us about it because we
actually don't care
[Music]
[Music]